a new baskin robbins has opened up in
town and it is celebrating the classic
and the modern rocky got to stop by and
check it out
my name is laura this is my first baskin
robbins
we officially opened on october 1st it
was a long time in waiting
we are doing special offers every week
to help bring in the community and
celebrate with the community for our
grand opening
so our vibe's all about flavoring every
moment and saving those moments and
creating them
those memories with your kids or your
family your spouse
you know that date night that you're on
so some of our special elements
we have the mural so every new moment
store has a mural that's specific
to their location i really created my
mural with lots of childhood memories
for myself so things that i remember
doing with my family
so we have the lake i used to always go
out with my brother so i loved it i had
to include it
and then we have kind of old vegas and
new vegas so old vegas is very dear to
my heart i used to go there a lot with
my grandparents so
it's special we also have vegas vic in
there
iconic right along with our baskin
mascot
the dog we have a new topping station as
well
and all sorts of different fancy cones
so we have lots of
waffle cones dipped in premium chocolate
topped with sprinkles
or chopped almonds along with the sugar
and cake cones the more traditional ones
and then we also have a novelty case now
with snackable
take home ice cream dipped in premium
chocolate some of our best sellers right
now
are chocolate dip bananas which are to
die for
and then we have chocolate dipped roll
cakes smoothie bars and chocolate dipped
fuller pizzas but a lot of people don't
know that our cakes are customizable
so with 24 hours notice we can make any
of the 36 flavors that we have in our
store of ice cream
for your ice cream cake along with
chocolate or white cake
and our designs are completely
customizable and they're made in house
by our
fabulous cake decorators okay laura we
talked about the new stuff here at
batman's but
i'm kind of a classic girl i like jamoka
that's my favorite ice cream ever
okay it's definitely a favorite around
here let's get you a scoop okay you know
what would you
what you would like that in ooh a waffle
cone
perfect we have a waffle bowl they're
made in-house fresh every day waffle
bowl perfect let me get that started for
you
[Music]
so this is our new topping station we
talked about earlier what kind of
toppings can i get to customize your
jamoka
oh okay i like to keep it simple so
let's go with almonds
and i see these nice brownie chunks yeah
they're delicious some brownie bites for
you
[Music]
and here you go your jamoca with
brownies and almonds
enjoy oh my gosh this reminds me of
childhood for sure
everybody has that childhood favorite
ice cream in the world
definitely how does it taste perfect
visit this special baskin robbins shop
monday through sunday from 11 a.m to 10
p.m
on south maryland parkway near silverado
you can call them at 725-204-1112
and take advantage of their special
offer a buy one sunday and get a second
one for 99 cents until
sunday november 1st just make sure to
mention this offer
and get your discount jc alex